-Charli,
welcome back to the show.
You look fantastic. Thank you
so much for coming back.
-Thank you for having me.
-The first time
you were here,
I want to say, it was three
and a half years ago
or something like that,
and we were talking.
We're both excited because
you had 32 million followers
and on TikTok, and it was like,
"Wow, that's awesome."
Here we are.
That's not that long ago,
three and a half years ago,
you're at 151 million followers.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Is that crazy?
-I mean, to me,
it's like, I can --
Like, this is a lot of people,
and I get so nervous.
So to think that I actually post
for that many people
is absolutely insane.
-Yeah.
-I can't really
understand it,
but I feel like
it's better that way,
because I can be less nervous.
-Yeah. Well, how old are you
when you first started?
-I was 15.
-15.
-On the show last time,
I was 15.
-Good for you, buddy.
That's so tough.
I mean, you stayed strong.
I mean, that must be
a lot of pressure, you know,
to start a business
and keep going and
and keep thinking of new ideas.
And then you have the show,
and now your whole family
is involved now.
Do you ever go back
and watch your old TikToks?
-I do and I make fun
of myself a lot
because it is so embarrassing.
But it's also fun
to go down memory lane
and be like, "Oh, my goodness,
this outfit was atrocious,
but, look, it was so cute.
I was a baby."
-Yeah, yeah. You still are.
You still are.
I wanted to ask you something,
because I saw "Vanity Fair."
They did a thing.
You did a lie-detector test.
You know what I'm about to say?
-Mm-hmm.
-Yeah, you love Dunkin' Donuts.
-I do.
-Okay, well, let's just watch
this lie-detector test.
-Do you actually like Dunkin'
as much as you say you do?
-Yes, and I shamelessly
promote them so much.
No, I'm such a fan
of Dunkin' Donuts.
-I'm happy that they're doing,
like, cool stuff, though.
-Do you think you like Dunkin'
more than this person?
-Yes.
-Do you know who that is?
-No.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You don't know
who Ben Affleck is?
-No, I do,
and I've, like, fully had
conversations with him before.
And, like, I know who --
That's why it's so unb--
My sister clowned me
for that so hard
the entire ride back.
I was so embarrassed.
-But that's hilarious.
So like, "Yeah, I love --"
"You like it better
than this person?"
And you just blanked?
-Because I just, like --
I know how much --
I've had two coffees
already today, you know?
Like, I --
-Yes.
You were in the zone
of Dunkin' Donuts.
-I know how much I love it,
and it's more than...
-Anyone.
-...anyone.
-Yeah, including that person
who, at the time,
you didn't know.
-Now I've looked
at the photos,
I feel like we can be equal.
-Oh, my God. That's so funny.
You were telling me
backstage, though,
that you actually had a great
meeting with Jennifer Lopez...
-Yeah.
-...who is like --
Gosh, we have that in common.
She is unbelievable.
We both love Jennifer Lopez.
-I love her.
She was the absolute sweetest.
Every single time
I've spoken to her,
she, like,
can see inside my brain
and tell me exactly
what I need to hear
without even knowing.
Like, genuinely,
my dream when I was younger
was to be
a backup dancer for her.
That was all that
I ever wanted in life.
-Me too.
-I'm such a fan.
We still can.
-We still can, yeah.
Jennifer, if you're watching,
we're in. Yeah.
-If you need us.
-She is just the best, right?
She is a pro.
When she comes on the show,
I mean, she -- Her in concert.
Go -- If she tours again --
Well, she will.
-But --
-She's insane.
-A professional.
She puts the work in, man.
-It's incredible.
-Yeah.
I know Halloween is coming up,
and you're a big fan
of Halloween.
Can you say what
you're dressing up as? No?
-I have, like, a list,
quite a long list,
in my notes of --
I work on it all year long,
add to it every week, you know?
But, so far, I only have
like one or two locked down.
I want to do Boo
from "Monsters, Inc.",
because I have the bob,
and I feel like it
just kind of works, you know?
-Okay. That's good.
-But, I mean, my boyfriend
and I were trying to do,
like, cute couples costumes,
but we're so indecisive
that we just, like,
can't actually get it together.
-Yeah.
-We have time.
-You do have a little time.
Yeah. Yeah.
You have like a --
Yeah, you have like a week.
You don't really have time,
to really be honest.
Your career
has actually blown up.
It's so cool to watch on TikTok.
Now you turn it into
a business now.
You have a shoe line.
Talk about this.
How fun is that?
-It's crazy. I mean,
all I really know about shoes
is the fact
that I wear them every day,
so I don't know
how it actually works,
but we have such an amazing team
behind us
that can, you know --
We're in heels a lot.
There's three girls
in the family.
We're all constantly, like,
blisters, everything hurts.
So it's been really fun to take
my favorite parts of shoes
and my least favorite parts of
shoes and work it all together
and make them comfortable,
stylish, cute,
get to pick the colors,
the shapes,
the silhouettes, the styles.
So it's really fun.
-I mean, you have everything.
You have, like --
You have slides.
You have sneakers.
I'm like, it's so --
Actually,
you wore them in today.
I was like, "You should just
wear them out with your dress.
Why not?"
They're, like --
They're cute sneakers.
But that's wild that you go,
"Yeah, I had this idea
and I'm going to make it real."
And you're making
all this stuff a reality.
-I know. It's insane.
-I'm so happy for you, buddy.
-Thank you!
-Really. I'm a big...
[ Cheers and applause ]
And the show,
"The D'Amelio Show,"
is streaming on Hulu.
-Yes.
-How is the family holding up?
How's the parents?
Are they going -- Yeah, is it
going to their head, the fame?
-You know, the fam is good.
We are together a lot.
It's great.
I mean, I live with my older
sister and we work together,
so we spend quite
a lot of time together.
You know, sisters -- we argue,
but we love each other.
-A lot of family bonding.
-Yeah. A lot.
-Yeah. We love it every time
you come by.
Thank you so much,
and congrats on the show
and on the shoes, as well.
-Thank you!
-Charli D'Amelio, everybody.
Season 3 of "The D'Amelio Show"
is streaming now on Hulu.
Victoria Monét
performs for us after the break.
Stick around, everybody.